[Music]
it's one of the biggest global
catastrophes in living memory
killing millions and causing 10 trillion
dollars in economic damage
but a year into the pandemic and we
still don't know the answer to one
question
where did covet 19 come from
scientists originally thought the most
likely origin was a wet market
in wuhan china where the virus may have
jumped from animals to humans
but wuhan is also home to two
laboratories focused on coronavirus
research
and there's mounting suspicion the virus
could have leaked
from a lab so what's the evidence
our experts answer your questions
what are the main theories of where
covet 19 came from
and is there any evidence
[Music]
so one of the first ideas was that this
virus jumped naturally
from bats through an intermediate animal
sold
on a local market in wuhan and novel
pathogens
often uh emerge just like this from
wildlife
and we expect events like this to occur
and this seemed very much like another
one of those occurrences
um however um the other idea
is that um you know hang on a minute
there happens to be one of the global
centers for coronavirus research
in that very town perhaps this novel
pathogen
actually came from that laboratory the
evidence for lab leak
is almost entirely circumstantial
um in that there's evidence that it
could have happened
and things that would have allowed it to
happen turn out to have
been true so yes there were samples of
coronaviruses of various sorts in that
lab
yes um there was work being done on
those coronaviruses
not all of it was done in the highest um
security laboratories and so
those things put together show you that
yes this
could have happened they don't show you
that it did happen why was the lab leak
theory dismissed initially
and what came to light to change
people's minds
i certainly think that the u.s media was
quite single-minded in its rejection of
the lab leak theory and that definitely
was for political reasons um and
remember that trump was conducting a
very kind of
racist anti-asian campaign
directed at the chinese at the time and
so it was difficult
to see this as anything more than a sort
of racist attack
when the who investigations team came
back
from china earlier this year the head of
the who said something quite interesting
he said all theories remained on the
table
and at the time the world's media had
been coming to the conclusion
uh that a natural origin was much more
likely
and he really kind of changed the tone
of the debate at that point and after
that
uh it seems to me scientists did feel
a lot more emboldened to say hang on a
minute
we do need to look into this a bit
further and we started to see
a decided shift in the scientific
community
if there has been a lab leak how will we
know if it was deliberate or accidental
well if the chinese were deliberately
going to
uh release a virus i think they would be
very foolish to do so
right next to um their institute of
virology
um you know presumably that they would
uh release this
uh this this virus next to the americans
institute for virology so i i just think
that um you know if you're going to
deliberately
bioengineer a weapon uh then then
releasing it just sort of right outside
the lab is a pretty dumb thing to do and
i don't think that they would have done
that
that's so good
is there any chance covert 19 was
man-made
and how can scientists tell this is
where
a lot of the hottest debate is actually
taking place
the virus has got oddities in its um
genetic makeup
at the same time you would expect it to
have auditors in its genetic makeup
because most viruses aren't suddenly
leaping out of bats and killing people
all around the world so
clearly it's going to be a virus of
concerning lethality
the question of whether that has come
about because of engineering
is one that people are really debating
at a molecular level
um in labs around the world at the
moment i think the thing to
remember here is that evolution is
really
cunning and so things that you don't
expect evolution to have done
that may just be because you haven't
been paying attention there's a
there's a sort of like assumption that
because something is odd
it's unnatural which i think is given
excessive weight
in some of these debates saying that
evolution
can't do something is the sort of thing
that ends up with evolution coming up
and biting you in the ass
um it's also uh the case that the wuhan
institute of virology was working on
modifying
um back coronaviruses um in 2015 they
published a paper describing
how they had created a chimera of a bat
and a mouse virus
so we know that that kind of work was
being done at the institute
um i've heard rumors uh
that they were working on other chimeras
as well
and that is harder to um verify
um but this is certainly one of the
allegations that's
sort of swirling around at the moment
how is the investigation
into the origins of the virus being
conducted
china is not feeling in a cooperative
mood
we're also waiting for more information
on the early cases of kobig 19
um that uh emerged in wuhan
uh still this raw data hasn't
been provided biden has said to his
intelligence community
you know have a big push and uh
we'd like you to report back on what you
can find in the next 90 days
but you know as time goes on and with
the chinese stonewalling
it is really hard to see how these
investigations
can proceed and also i'm kind of
troubled by
you know how little was done by the
chinese
before the who went out there and um
there was a sort of emissary from who
sent out in the middle of the last year
and his report
uh suggested the chinese had really done
very little
uh in terms of epidemiological
investigations in wuhan
since january and so i i can't think of
a good reason
why you wouldn't want to do lots of
epidemiological investigations or you
wouldn't want
to kind of look at those early cases and
so the sort of suspicious side of me
says well
is the reason that they don't want to do
these investigations is that they kind
of already know what the answer is
or that they're afraid of knowing what
the answer is
if the lab leak is confirmed will china
be held accountable
so no for two reasons china won't be
held accountable
uh one is that it's a big powerful
country
and um it's going to be difficult for
any
country to hold it accountable for
anything um and the other reason
uh is more philosophical is that
holding china accountable for this
actually works against
what we need in the future and that is
kind of a radical transparency about
what's going on in these laboratories
and
where mistakes are being made and that
requires kind of quite a
culture of acceptance and the more we
talk
about accountability and about blame
the more we're going to you know
make certain that laboratories are going
to be much more secretive about the
mistakes that they make
and that will also mean that we can't
learn from each other about
how to prevent accidents based on all
your reporting and research
what do you think happened all right
well i
i get asked this question all the time
and i honestly
i go back and forth on the question and
have done
uh since i started reporting on the lab
leak theory
uh in april of last year and
i think it's a frustrating question to
get asked
because it's impossible to answer
properly there's so much information
that i would want to be able to weigh up
those different likelihoods that i just
don't have
when i have um people who are really
respectable
like uh the great biologist uh ralph
barrich saying
that he thinks it's probably natural but
we should look at the lab leak then
i think that that sounds really really
sensible
um how i mean i think it's still
probably the case that among the people
that i talk
um a natural occurrence is seen as more
likely
but they could be wrong and they know is
there a chance we might never find out
the true origin of covet 19
i think that it's easier to destroy
evidence in a laboratory and in
databases than it is in the wild
so if it turned out that there really
wasn't evidence
for a zoonotic spillover but there also
wasn't evidence for lab leak i suspect
that would
edge me towards believe towards thinking
things when we're all nefarious
but you know absence of evidence isn't
evidence of absence you know if you
can't find it in
the world you may just not be looking in
the right places and
looking hard enough and evolution will
come and get you
the question of the origin of
covid19 you know a pandemic that has
killed potentially um upwards of about
10 million people
is it's a really compelling question and
one that i've
kind of felt slightly obsessed with uh
you know
since the start of last year and
you know it's hard to know whether we're
going to get to a resolution
um but nonetheless you know it is a
question that will
keep coming up until we do get good
answers
and it's it's sort of taking on uh
you know a bit of the aura isn't it of
things like you know who shot kennedy
and
um you know how marilyn monroe died it's
become a very much a sort of iconic
question
certainly of our time um and i think you
know as the
months and years go on if it if it
hasn't
been sufficiently well answered we'll
continue to sort of reverberate
um you know over the decades until um
you know the next one comes along
i'm natasha loda the health policy
editor of the economist
you can read our coverage of covid19 by
clicking on the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe